foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
so
cheers
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
good evening everyone i am so glad that
you are here tonight whether this is
your first time or your 104th time which
would mean that for the last two years
you have been here every single sunday
because it is our two year anniversary
so
happy birthday and is it a birthday or
an anniversary can it be both
birth of bursary
that i like that so my name is kelly
tilford my husband josh and i lead an
online
meetup group shout out to our online
group
and um
something that's really i'm going to
give you a teeny bit of our backstory we
just relocated here
from chattanooga tennessee um we had
been attending the table online for the
last two years
and six years prior to that my husband
and i who both grew up in the church
loved jesus with all our hearts actually
walked away saying we're done we're done
if this is what church is about if this
is what it's going to do
we don't want any part of it and so
when josh's brother brett and his whole
crew of people launched this church
the five values being inclusive
vulnerability communal
thoughtful
eclectic
when those were the five values i
thought yeah i can be a part of
something like that because those are
five values that i personally hold super
duper dear
and um
here we are now in person getting to be
a part of this beautiful community that
actually holds those values and acts on
them it's the heartbeat of this church
it's not just something that they say
it's not just written pretty on the
walls or on the website it is the
heartbeat of this church and it has been
such a gift to us and our meetup group
has been such a gift and it is just an
honor to be here on the two-year
mark um and with that being said
partnering and actually being a part of
not just saying the things but doing the
things graham is gonna
shh
graham come here graham
he's gonna share an opportunity to
volunteer and put those actions those
words into actions and they want to
steal the microphone from me
um okay so we have done five loaves in
the past we're going to do it again on
november 20th from 10 to 12. that's in
saxy it's a
they've grown a lot and so they need
help hanging clothes and sorting food
and making snack bags so if you guys
want to do that we have a sign up genius
that's on our at the meetup on facebook
and in brett's newsletter
just the more the merrier
and kids can come too
one of the things that we super love at
the table is not just actually extending
our hands but people joining in and so
last weekend one of the things that came
to fruition was the trunk or treat
super big shout out to joe and angie and
brittany for making that possible from
the chili down to the cars that were
decorated to the kids that joined in it
was
super duper lovely and fun
and just again such a gift because you
can say things all day but if you're not
practicing what you preach what is it
worth
um so if y'all will pray with me and
we'll enter into a time of worship
god i i praise you and i thank you for
the table that has been set in front of
us
lord i pray that
everyone who comes here tonight whether
they are needing rest or grace or peace
or some fuel to enter into another week
that you would meet us here and that you
would rain those down
that the values of this
church would be reinstilled that we
would carry out another year
of loving and serving you
and just finding you and finding those
the gifts of your spirit god
and the ones that are not of you that we
would set them aside and keep finding
finding you here and finding you in the
world and giving
giving your goodness to those around us
in your son's most precious name amen
amen
thanks kelly love having josh and kelly
close by now instead of just from afar
and it's been so great having a part of
our community and great hearing your
voice up here
yay
um i wanted to make a quick announcement
that one of the things that is always a
challenge to me in my role at the table
is wanting to find
music worship music songs that are
authentic to our community and not just
go with whatever is the most popular
christian song on the radio or the most
popular hill song going on or whatever
but really lyrics are extremely
important to me and
in doing that i mean it's like my
kryptonite same time because i will x
out so many songs just because i'm like
oh that one line and sometimes karen and
brett have to be like mindy it's really
okay that one line is probably not gonna
kill it and i'm like i just can't
believe it with my whole heart so we
can't sing it but
but i do really
strive to find songs that will feel true
for all of us um so if you have a
suggestion that like you have a song
that really connects with you and you
would love to hear it at times people
have thrown out different things and
they've just clicked sometimes and
sometimes i hear something and i'm like
that's awesome i can't leave it
personally but
i will still love to listen to your
suggestions at home even if it's
something that won't work for our band
to play or whatever but um i would love
to hear from you guys and get feedback
on that so our little offering box
that's back there that y'all drop stuff
into sometimes if you ever want to just
write something down on a piece of paper
or one of our offering envelopes or
whatever and just stick it in that box a
song suggestion i would love to have
those um so i just wanted to throw that
out there as a little you know keep it
in the back of your hat if you're
listening to music and it's like man
this connects it feels like our
community feels authentic to who we are
stick it in there and i will take a
listen i would love it
um so we're gonna get going tonight i'm
really excited because if you were here
on the very first night
that we began our services um we started
with this song called ring the bells and
it's by uh johnny it was a duo mashup
between johnny swim and drew holcomb and
the neighbors and um it's just one of
those songs that has always felt so true
to our community and the first time i
heard it i was like this is what it's
all about like it was time for us like
kelly was saying it was time for us to
start practicing what we were preaching
and thus the table you know because we
were living out something where we
couldn't make all of our values actually
come to fruition in our community so we
started this table so that we could live
out the things that we believed in our
hearts were true about the gospel and
about jesus and the way he loves and the
way he includes so anyways y'all stand
with us even if you don't know this song
please give us a little support clap
your hands stomp your feet it's a fun
one
and i hope you enjoy it
[Applause]
we say mercy won't be rationed that's
what we're fighting for
ring the bells
captioning not available
and i ain't the only
we can sing
ring the bells
this time i mean
[Music]
[Applause]
that was fun
awesome all right noel's going to get us
going on this
[Music]
every next
through every heartbreak
through every circumstance
i believe you are
the way
the truth
the life
i
believe you are
the way
promise
you are the one i love
i believe you are
the way
the truth
the
[Music]
the truth
and it's a new horizon
and i'm set on you
you meet me here today with mercies that
i knew
and all my fears and doubts
they can all come to
because they can't stay long
when i'm here with you
it's a new horizon
and i'm set on you
and you made me
hit me
my
fears way
the
truth i believe you are the way
it's a new
horizon and i'm set on you
and you meet me here
all come today
the true
i believe you are
[Music]
thank you god for making room even for
our questions and our doubts and our
uncertainties and somewhere in the mix
of all of that we still find
this
still small voice that says i love you i
am here i am with you
[Music]
i created you from the foundations of
the earth
i'm doing a new thing
i can redeem it i can make it new again
thank you god
we're going to move into the prayers of
the people and if this is your first
time with us
it's a tradition passed down through
christian history
and um i'm gonna read part of a prayer
together and at the end of each line
there will be words up on the screen in
red that we can all say
together and then we're gonna leave a
little bit of space
um and we just ask that you guys enter
into this with us if you feel
comfortable and share a name or a
situation that you're carrying on your
heart
um
if there's someone that is struggling or
just something that's weighing on you we
just give you room and space to lift
that up and as a community we want to
carry that with you in this moment we
want to share
in that burden and that struggle um
and
then i'll wrap it up with another brief
prayer right at the end
and if you're joining us online we would
love for you to be a part of this as
well so please leave
anything that's on your heart tonight in
the comments and we will share that so
that we can all
participate as much as possible even at
a distance
[Music]
jesus for this city of saxi texas and
for every city and community and all of
those who live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the sick and the old for the widow
and the orphaned for the injured and the
suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed
the unemployed and the destitute for
prisoners and captives and for all who
remember and care for them
we pray to you
because lord we know that you love us
and that you hear us and so now we lift
these names and situations up to you
[Music]
angelina
for these names and moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we've
kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing and hope
peace
and the deep sense of your presence god
amen
[Music]
we're going to move into a song that we
haven't done before and i asked jesse um
to lead it if you guys want to sit back
and just take in these words
i just feel like it would be a beautiful
thing for us to reflect on together
especially after moving out of that time
where we're kind of acknowledging some
of the burdens that we carry
to also acknowledge the one who carries
them with us and for us
so i hope this is a meaningful moment to
you it's definitely a song that has been
moving to me
as a matter of fact just a quick story
um
you guys probably know that uh my family
and brett's family all live in one house
and my niece eve lost her dog last week
and it was surprisingly emotional for me
just because watching her
in her pain with this puppy that she's
had since she was four and is just kind
of like her essence walking around on
this earth it was just really beautiful
and sad to watch her grieve this as a 12
year old and the night that um maggie
and brett went out driving looking
around for him and i laid in her bed
with her and she just
she's very like physical affection she
just like laid her body on top of me
she's not tiny
we're about the same size now she's just
like covering me in this hug
and just she's a feeler to the nth
degree and feels things very strongly
and
um she loves music and i just said like
eve do you want me to play this song to
you that i just feel like is very
emotional and she was like yes
and i turned on this song and just put
it on repeat because to me it's just
been such a
just a gift really this song has just
been a gift so i hope it can be the same
you saw me first
you let me in when i was at my worst
and the moment when i heard you say my
name
it's the first time in so long i'm not
afraid
i'm not afraid
[Music]
you are the voice that calms the storm
inside me
castle walls and stand around me oh this
time my
guardians here
you are the light that shines in every
tunnel there in the past you'll be there
tomorrow
life your love was breaking through
it's always
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's always
[Laughter]
been you
[Music]
my northern star
you'll never be the compass of my heart
oh i just wanna be right where you are
right where you are
you are the voice that calms the storm
inside me castle walls the sand around
me all this time my guardian was you
[Music]
you are the light that shines in every
tunnel there in the past you'll be there
tomorrow
all my life your love is breaking
through
it's always been yeah
it's always been
[Music]
it's always been you
it's always been yeah
who stood with me in the fire he was you
he was always you who pulled me out of
the water he was you
it was always you who carried me on
their shoulders it was you
it was always
[Applause]
[Music]
you are the voice that calms the storm
inside me
cast the walls
[Music]
you are the light that shines in every
tunnel
there in the past you'll be there
tomorrow
all my life your love was breaking
god thank you for carrying us
even when we're at our worst
thank you for loving us
for calling out our best
for believing in more than we can see
even for this community god for the
table thank you for seeing it before we
even could
and for carrying it god even through
covid and
all the crazy turns that have come that
we didn't even know were going to be a
thing
and there you were
steady and faithful beside us
here you are now with each family
each individual
loving us guiding us carrying us through
and we believe it will always be you god
you will always be our rock you will
always be
the one we return to
your love is the anchor for us
it is our holding place it is our
shelter
and it is also the thing that pushes us
out into the world to make a difference
to bring light and healing and
redemption
it is the thing that we hang on to and
believe in for ourselves when we are at
our darkest
that you are that light breaking through
you are that hope you are that healing
[Music]
jesus continue to meet us
each day each moment each breath god
would you be
the one that we're returning to
finding in our midst would you be the
thing that we're calling out into our
lives your love your goodness your
forgiveness and compassion
your justice
your mercies
help us to find you here
[Music]
thank you god for each person in this
room each person who has joined us for
the last two years
god thank you for their lives for their
stories for the way that they embody our
values
be with them
continue to lead us and guide us
and open our hearts as brett shares
tonight god help us to receive
everything that you have
for us and it's in your name i pray
amen
[Music]
thank you guys so much for worshiping
with us if y'all want to turn and greet
someone around you welcome them say
hello brett's gonna come on up and get
started with this message
all right
i had your seats
i've got an hour and a half sermon so
i'm gonna need all the time i'm just
joking
um
well good evening everyone grace and
peace it's really really good to um yeah
just to be with all of you and
um man that was a beautiful time of
worship thank you uh mindy and
um
jesse and uh
well just man powerful powerful to
worship god to just i don't know just to
be in his presence you know
um beautiful so i want to welcome uh all
of you but uh that of course includes uh
everyone joining us online
we love you a lot and um and as well as
anyone who is new um thank you for for
being here can take a lot of courage uh
to walk through those doors um and you
know just enter into a new space a new
place new people and kind of wonder like
oh gosh what's this gonna be like and so
i hope um you just have a sense of
welcome
and uh yeah and just know that you're
really wanted here so thank you for
joining us um so we are in uh this is
part three in our series titled first
peter
um so the series is actually titled
first peter part one because we're just
making it through chapter one
uh right now
and uh in the next few weeks kind of
leading up to christmas and then we'll
take a break for advent christmas season
and then we'll jump back to first peter
for part two and kind of go from there
so we're just kind of working our way
through through peter so um i think week
one was like we just covered two verses
this week's not much better we're
covering three verses so
like just make plotting our way through
it but um
uh see two weeks ago we did uh what was
that six verses verses three through
nine so you know that was better we're
making we're making our way um so uh
tonight will be versus 10 through 12 of
first peter and the title of the message
is the pattern
the pattern
so let's go ahead and read
first peter chapter 1
verses 10 through 12.
concerning this salvation
the prophets who spoke of the grace that
was to come to you searched intently and
with the greatest care
trying to find out the time
in the circumstances
to which the spirit of christ in them
was pointing when he predicted the
sufferings of the messiah and the
glories that would follow
it's kind of interesting that he
describes how the prophets in their
writing like you can go through you know
of course the biblical prophets um in
the bible you know zechariah
um
isaiah which we'll read in a minute
there's a a number of um
texts that kind of you know are
allusions to to who christ was going to
be and so it's interesting that he says
they were it was like christ it was
through the holy spirit christ in them
was actually doing the prophesying it
was like christ himself was doing the
pointing to who he would be and how he
would work um it's kind of interesting
way to think of what what's going on in
prophecy so verse 12 it was revealed to
them that they were not serving
themselves but you when they spoke of
the things that have now been told you
by those who have preached the gospel to
you by the holy spirit sent from heaven
in fact even angels
long
to look into these things
so you can tell this this whole little
section here it's like all about
prophecy it's all about um
you know people these prophets kind of
foretelling who christ would be and such
and i'm quite familiar with this because
i grew up in kind of a whole wing of the
church um
that was like really into biblical
prophecy i don't know if anyone has had
the privilege of being in that you know
kind of kind of those wings
of of the church i think it's kind of
more protestant as opposed to catholic
and then even among protestants it's not
necessarily like the mainline folks the
you know i don't know if like the
methodists so much good of that maybe
you know memphis or presbyterians i
don't think it's it's kind of more than
non-denominational church the bible
churches you know the maybe certain
wings of baptists and whatever so i was
kind of part of the non-denominational
world
so we were like all about the prophecies
you know all about the uh and not so
much in necessarily a pentecostal
charismatic sense of like people
speaking prophetically to you oh there's
a little bit of that but it was more
about the biblical prophecies the um all
the passages that kind of foretold about
jesus and uh and not just the first
coming of christ um but even kind of
getting into the book of revelation then
like the whole second coming and you
know all the things there um
so i'm like yeah these are like my roots
you know i'm just kind of imagining this
this type of passage is just the thing
that we're like yes
finally we're like getting to the
prophecy stuff you know that like you
can imagine um
the the uh young vet just being like
finally brett why don't you preach on
this more often um because that was yeah
this is kind of our world in fact i can
remember we did this uh this thing
called bethlehem marketplace and we
would turn our sanctuary our church
building into like this whole kind of
into the city of bethlehem and so my job
i was uh i've served a number of roles
in my young years um
and one of them i was the um
one of the i was this the synagogue
like pupil you know when i was like 12
and i'd be sitting there with the rabbi
and i would kind of i was sort of like
the shill like i was like do not the
prophet's foretell that you know the
messiah will be born in bethlehem you
know and then this was prepubescent
brett and so uh and then i've actually
i've gone back like years ago
i watched a video someone had gone
through with a camcorder and recorded
this and y'all that is no joke how i
sounded i was so i was like oh my gosh
18 year old brett was not impressed with
12 year old brad's like what but that
was kind of my job right was to don't
they say and doesn't the prophet
zechariah doesn't he predict that they
will you know come from bethlehem or
that that the the jacob there there will
be a a scepter that shall rise out of
jacob a uh the anointing of christ will
come out of israel you know i just this
was my job right so all that to say in
this
through all of the prophecies um and
that was
so important this by the way is not in
my notes i'm just kind of going right
now on this part um but this one you
know so i'll just say this i'm familiar
you know like this kind of world of
bible prophecies all the things about
jesus we get like real excited and um
now i will say i'm not at some point i
need to do a series in the book of
revelation because i think there's some
better ways to approach the book of
revelation that's not just like it's
like a playbook of the end you know um i
think there's a lot in revelation that's
actually talking about the roman empire
um so you know there's
we'll get into that at some point um but
in terms of this first coming of jesus i
i must admit that
a lot of the scriptures are um i mean
they're remarkable they really are it's
quite remarkable um to read so i want to
give you a taste for those who are maybe
not familiar like who are these
what are these passages what are these
prophets that peter has in mind you know
what are these texts that he's sort of
like they were you know trying to
discern even angels long to kind of look
into these things and see the future you
know what is he talking about so i'm
going to give you i'll give you two
examples the first is psalm 22. the
second is isaiah 53. so let's start with
psalm 22.
this almost writes dogs surround me
a pack of villains encircles me they
pierce my hands and my feet
all my bones are on display people stare
and gloat over me they divide my clothes
among them in cast lots for my garment
right if you just kind of heard that
passage
um
you might think and you're all familiar
with the story of jesus and crucifixion
right you would probably just assume
like oh cool so that's like new
testament you know um but no you know
this is a psalm this is written hundreds
of years uh before jesus was in the
flesh
um so it's pretty i mean it's pretty
remarkable here's another one this is um
from isaiah chapter 53 uh verses three
through seven really isaiah 52 as a
whole chapter in 53 they're both quite
remarkable um so this is just verses
three through seven
uh for he
was despised and rejected by mankind a
man of suffering and familiar with pain
like one from whom people hide their
faces he was despised and we held him in
low esteem
surely he took up our pain and bore our
suffering and yet we considered him
punished by god
stricken by him and afflicted
but he
was pierced
for our transgressions he was crushed
for our iniquities the punishment that
brought us peace was on him and by his
wounds we are healed we all like sheep
have gone astray each of us has turned
to our own way and the lord has laid on
him the iniquity of us all he was
oppressed and afflicted and yet he did
not open his mouth he was led like a
lamb to the slaughter and as a sheep
before its shearers is silent so he did
not open his mouth
i mean it's quite remarkable
right it's sort of like what is that is
that after jesus came like nope that's a
long time this is isaiah so
many hundreds of years before jesus
actually came in the flesh so you know
again if you're at all familiar with the
story it's quite remarkable and so i
think for good reason you know
christians kind of um
read these prophetic passages or even
before christianity came about even
before christ um the jewish people you
know read these texts and kind of
wondered who would this be you know what
what are the who is the he
that this is talking about you know
um and so i think rightly so christians
as well now in light of who christ is
right get very excited about texts like
psalm 22 isaiah chapter 52 53 the text
we just read you know it's like
it's like you know this is um this is
really cool
uh you know stuff like and and so um
what can happen
is um that over time we get kind of very
very very into biblical prophecy and we
begin to kind of
um should i go ahead and switch which
one you want me on let's see i need
wireless this one
check test
is that good
all right cool
so
um you know so people get very into this
um and they start to get kind of into
all sorts of like you know not just the
big picture but like into the minutia
into the details there's whole
ministries that launch into just like
unpacking all of the little biblical
prophecies and things um
and what i want to name is that i think
that's not what peter's actually getting
at i don't think he's kind of trying to
push us towards um that sort of thing
um
in other words i don't think the reason
peter brings these up um is because he's
trying to like prove
that um jesus is the messiah that he's
trying to like um
convince them
that the bible really is trustworthy and
so the prophets you know look they
predicted the future therefore
it's all true you know i don't think
that's quite what um peter's getting
that instead i think there's some key
words in the text we just read that that
kind of get at peter's point in its two
words it's sufferings the sufferings and
the glories
the sufferings and the glories i think
this is the point let me read it again
this is verse 11. so the prophets they
were trying to find out the time and the
circumstances to which the spirit of
christ in them was pointing when he
predicted the sufferings of the messiah
in the glories that would follow
suffering in glory
and in other words the remarkable thing
about this text
psalm 22 isaiah 53 and others
is not
simply that like look they predict the
future and this is where i think people
go a little wrong because they're just
like wow the future look at that it
predicts the future you know we're like
okay you know what's that's cool
um but it would be a little bit of an
exercise in missing the point because
what happens is we can get so obsessed
with the fact that it predicts future
that we
we start to um
almost
miss the message
right miss
um
the pattern
um miss
how it is god is working in the world
and that's the most important thing
right in other words we shouldn't i
don't think the point of isaiah 53 is
that we read that text
and we just get like wow look at that it
predicted jesus
and then kind of move on
instead what we should be shocked by
what we should say is absolutely
remarkable
is precisely how it describes god's son
how it describes
what god will do in the world
in other words notice
that how christ would come into the
world and what would he do
this is what's remarkable
he embraces
humility
and lowliness
and service
and suffering love
like that's the point
and and even think of isaiah 53 i think
is
it's just beautiful the way he describes
how how this messiah god's deliver will
do what will just bear
we'll just take on
just all of our crap
and our evil and our sin and i mean the
language he uses that we just read is
you know infirmities which is just our
just the sickness that plagues the human
race like both physical sickness and
just moral ethical sickness like we're
just terrible i mean think of it even
thinking of jesus crucifixion
it gives us even more clarity like it's
almost worse than isaiah predicted
right we know it's not only just evil in
the kind of an abstract sense it's like
he literally takes on our torture
he takes on this this just a malevolence
in our lies
just and of of politics of the political
realm of the social realm of religion i
mean the whole thing he just bears it
all he just takes it into his very body
and and then what does he do he
transforms it
he
theologians would say he transmutes it
he he transforms it through
suffering love
and
that's
the point
right that's the pattern like this is
how god works in the world in other
words
it would be easy to think
that god's messiah god's deliverer
would show up and would just be the
baddest dude on the block
right he would show up and he would
freaking kill his enemies and all those
unbelievers
and all those terrible people who
haven't been living right and like this
is in ways and there's other passages
actually you can find in the old
testament that point to something more
along those lines
like this is kind of who liver you know
it's gonna it's payback time
and this is what's so this like this is
the point of psalm 22 isaiah 53 he was
pierced for our transgressions he was
crushed for our iniquities he took on
all of my crap and my sin and my shame
he just bore it all in his very body and
then he just transformed it through
suffering love
and then thinking of like the gospels
right then all the disciples scatter i
mean they just treat them tearfully and
they were all run you know and then he
shows up in their midst
what does he say his first word on his
lips and the gospel of john peace
peace be with you peace be upon you he
speaks word of peace he speaks a word of
forgiveness
he speaks a word of reconciliation
and then what does he do he he calls he
creates a community
and he says
this is the pattern
this is how we're going to do it
like this is how i work in the world i
don't show up and slaughter all my
enemies and like be the victor and like
no no
no it's the cross
it's psalm 22.
it's isaiah 53
it's the pattern like
that's the point can you see the
difference a little bit in
getting really obsessed with bible
prophecy
and yet
completely missing the point
can you see how this happens right where
you get so interested like whoa are
there other passages like psalm 22 there
are and then you just go and you get in
all the minutiae and you're just
obsessed with all the details and you
can quote like all the prophets and all
the things and yet the whole point is
like okay well that's interesting like
good for you
you know what that paul talks about
knowledge puffs up but love builds up
you know it can be this huge exercise
and just a messy knowledge just i know
all the prophecies i know all think
right when the whole question is like
have you discerned the pattern
do you understand what the prophets are
actually getting at
right that was their gene that was why
they were seers
it wasn't simply because they said the
messiah god's deliverer will come
right and they did that hundreds of
years before he actually came like well
awesome good job
but but the re the remarkable thing
about it is
is the how they discerned how it was god
would work in the world i want to sum it
up like this if you're a notetaker you
can write this down
what these prophecies reveal
is that it is not might or power or
violence that will save the world but is
the humility the lowliness and suffering
love of christ in those like him that's
it
that's that's first peter suffering
glory
right the path to glory the path to
exaltation the path to greatness in
god's eyes
is not what the world thinks it is
that's the point
it's like completely upside down and
unexpected
like it's the messiah was precisely the
person we did not foresee isn't it funny
how you know we kind of poke fun at like
oh they didn't they didn't see who jesus
was you know they didn't discern who
christ was you know if i were there i
would have probably not
right like let's be honest
probably not
because well just look at it today we're
every bit as obsessed with money
in power
you know what do we want in our leaders
like great kings and you know people
that look great on instagram and you
know like this is the way of the world
has always has been the way of the world
and likely will continue to be the way
of the world
until the kingdom of god just keeps
working its way just working its way
into the world as we slowly learn the
pattern like oh that's right
it's not might or power or violence that
will save the world oh that's right it's
humility it's lowliness it's service
it's it's suffering love because this
isn't just about well that's what jesus
did right he went to the cross for our
sins and so we believe on him and then
we get to go to heaven when we die and
then woohoo for us you know like well
that's not discipleship because
discipleship says that's who jesus was
and now i am following jesus
which means he lived the pattern
and so what do we do
we live the pattern
right we embrace how god works in the
world
um in fact
you know it's interesting that it's this
is not only
um kind of about um
how god does it but it's also the who
because again in kind of the ways of the
world is we're always looking for okay
we need like some powerful people like
if we're gonna have some influence in
this city which we'll actually get to
later in this message you know we gotta
we gotta win this city for christ well
then we need some really great people
we need some movers and shakers i hope
we can get the mayor here you know like
this is this is the way of the world you
say well that's what we need we need the
societal movers and shakers at this
church and then when we get them on our
side then we can use them or god will
use them by his grace and we will get
all of the other people right can you
see how this doesn't fit
the pattern
in fact uh this who extends even paul
discerned this by the way he he
understood this and this is why he
writes in first corinthians a hilarious
passage because he's writing into a
church
and he says this verse 27 but god has
chosen the foolish things of the world
to shame the wise god chose the weak
things of the world to shame the strong
god chose the lowly things of this world
and the despised things and the things
that are not to nullify the things that
are you know he's talking about he's
talking about us
which is kind of funny thing to like
look at a church like yep that's us
we're a bunch of nobodies
and let's be honest like not you know
not a lot of phds among us you know
not a lot of i don't know
billionaires
i don't know anyone have on their social
media following
five thousand fifty thousand ten
no not so much yeah we're just you know
kinda obscure nobodies
but this is the pattern
right because the world looks at it and
says well those people are just a bunch
of nobodies i don't even know why people
go to church
you know
but this is how god has chosen to work
in the world that's the pattern it's the
lowly it's the despised it's the no
bodies and just quietly he just kind of
sneaks up on the world
and he sneaks up on us too
as paul says he says and why is that by
the way why
because when we are weak
what
god is strong
because otherwise we get all the glory
and we think it's about us we brought
the kingdom we really we really brought
god to this city you know whatever
no no no that's not how it works right
you know in fact this isn't um even just
the christ pattern really honestly this
is like the biblical pattern if you kind
of read the bible with this pattern in
mind you'll see it all over the place
thinking back to for example like
abraham you know who we think in our
minds if you're familiar with abraham he
was sort of the first at least in the
biblical account the first kind of
monotheist the first person who trusted
the one god and kind of left the the
many gods of his own culture and was
kind of called by the one true god to
you know journey forth in faith and so
we kind of build abraham up in our minds
like whoa the father of the faith you
know three religions kind of look back
to him as like the guy christianity
judaism islam all all in the whole their
holy book like
abraham wow you know so that's easy to
think right like wow he must have been
so powerful and amazing and but if you
actually read the story um it's a little
bit funny because god shows up to him
and says abraham i'm going to make you
the father of you know generations of
people in fact look at the stars abraham
just look at him that your descendants
are going to be more than all that
and the book of romans chapter 4 points
out that when god showed up and told him
this abraham was 100 years old
can you see the irony right it was like
huh so you want me to have lots of kids
and then we're going to storm a whole
we're going to form a whole generation
or like house
in fact when god then showed up to his
wife sarah and said like sarah it's time
it's time you're going to have a son and
then through that sun there's going to
be whole generations i'm going to create
a people in this earth that are going to
follow me and love me and through them
all the nations of the world are going
to be blessed and he's got a whole plan
you know and what do you if you know the
story you know what sarah does she
laughs
why because she was 80.
right so he's a hundred she's 80 and
god's like all right it's perfect
here we go
right why would he do that because when
we are weak god is strong it's not
through might power and violence and our
genius strategies and our awesome plans
that god will save the world it's it's
through his goodness it's through it's
through an openness to him and then when
we're weak he's strong and he moves
through us
i think also another example um moses
right again we kind of have the charlton
heston movie moses in our minds you know
um
but that's just not accurate um when
moses when god shows up to moses and
kind of gives him a call
you know like we're gonna go and do this
thing in egypt and you're gonna set my
people free i'm gonna use you powerfully
if you actually know the story so
he had to flee egypt
um he was a murderer killed he killed a
man
um fled to the wilderness gets married
and just is a shepherd in obscurity for
40 years he was 40 when he fled
40 plus 40.
he's 80
right so can you can you see again how
god's like 80 years old and this is kind
of often people think of them as like
you know more of the twilight years
they're like okay i'm kind of my legacy
you know but
but what does god say god's like you're
just getting started moses
here we go we're ready now and moses is
like huh in fact moses starts to kind of
beg off like uh well i'm not honestly
i'm not like the smartest and i'm not
the most eloquent i'm not really what
you call a speaker or a leader of men
you know so he starts begging off like
maybe um what if aaron my brother-in-law
what if he does the talking i mean maybe
i'll go but if he does the talk you know
like this is just not a recipe for yes
success you know how to win friends and
influence people it's just not just not
it
what does god say looks at moses you're
perfect
you're perfect moses
because it's not
by might it's not my power
right this is not how god works it's
it's
this is the pattern
when we're weak he's
strong
so i want to help this land a little bit
as i wrap up kind of land like in your
own life you know because it could be a
little bit of like maybe a big picture
you know the pattern the biblical
pattern the christ pattern the
prophecies you know all a little bit out
there and so i want this to land in your
life
um i'll start with something personal
and then i'll talk about us as a
community um so first kind of
application a little takeaway for you
personal um what this means is that my
ordinary obscure quiet life is exactly
how the kingdom of god comes
see we're all chasing and we're just i
shouldn't say we're all i'll just say
we're all tempted
to chase
the big
the grand you know i want to be rich and
famous and powerful and like do the
thing and you know and like this is it's
just very easy to get pulled into that
vision right that's just the way the
world like you want to matter great well
then be awesome you know and be
extraordinary and
um
and
i mean not only is it unattainable since
not everyone
can be rich and powerful and famous and
right if everyone were that well then
like no one would be you know so it
doesn't even make mathematical sense
but still we're kind of chasing it um
but again when we
fix it um in that way like it sort of
can be about ego
you know and so i think this is what's
so beautiful is what christ invites us
into is just to make it like
more simple
like
um
it's about just being like jesus
wherever we find ourselves so some of
you are teachers i was talking to a
teacher right before the the service
it's a hard job
you know and you think
i don't know like is this the life i
envisioned for myself you know caring
for
you know 30 yelling seven-year-olds you
know
um
find yourself a teacher love well
love well this is how the kingdom of god
comes
maybe you're a
nurse
cleaning people's bedpans you know it's
not sexy to be a nurse like people maybe
i don't know what people imagine it to
be but it's hard
you know
uh love well
this is how the kingdom comes
mother father caring for young children
it's tough
love well
this is how the kingdom comes mid-level
manager corporation xyz you're like you
have no idea how boring my job is you
know
love well
love well this is how the kingdom of god
comes god uses you
right where you're at in your ordinary
obscure
quiet life
god uses you i
promise so that's the personal let's
speak to um in closing the corporate the
communal
um being a cool or powerful church is
not how the kingdom comes
it's just not how the kingdom comes
right um
and
and what i want to name this isn't so
much about pointing to other churches
and i don't like to bad mouth other
churches so we have enough problems of
our own so i don't need to look outside
i'll just say for us
that's there's going to be a temptation
right as we kind of have a vision and
something god calls us to and we want to
you know grow and and see god do great
things in people's life and that's all
beautiful right there can be a lot of
good intentions in that but oh i promise
you there will be a temptation my
friends no doubt
there will be a temptation that in that
process we lose our soul
we do
why because you can do church
and leave the pattern
far behind
and then what are you doing you're just
playing at church like you call you have
the label church on your building
but but because you think the kingdom of
god comes through amazing eloquence and
hilarious illustrations you know and big
buildings and
bigger budgets and you know whatever the
thing slick marketing like
you start to buy into that and all of a
sudden
lose your soul
because what's it actually about
um
relationships
love
service
humility
loneliness
and remaining weak
so that god can be strong god can be big
so that's the invitation for us as a
church for us as people and so as we um
take communion tonight i want us to
remember like enter into it
in that same um
in that posture of just remembering the
one who himself came in lowliness and
humility in service and suffering love
we remember him and then we enter into
solidarity and connection
of with him
so each of you should have a ziploc
bag and a cup if you don't um i know we
have a number of people here um
daryl's coming up the aisle and he has
some some extras if you need need a cup
and some bread we can get that to you
if you are joining us online
we would love for you to participate in
taking communion with us
so you can just grab some bread from
your fridge or if you got grape juice or
wine or whatever you got we'd love for
you to to be able to participate with us
um i'm going to walk you through it in
just a moment of kind of taking the
elements um as i read from first
corinthians 11. but before i do that i
also want to mention we practice what's
called an open table meaning if you're
here tonight and you would like to
participate in communion then you are
welcome to do it
um
you don't have to worry about having
like all the perfect theology or you
know whatever just if you something in
you wants to connect with christ then
go for it you do it
so let me um let me walk you through
this um
starting in verse 23 of first
corinthians chapter 11.
we'll start with the bread in just a
moment for i received from the lord
but i also passed on to you the lord
jesus on the night he was betrayed
he took bread
and when he'd given thanks he broke it
and he said this is my body which is for
you
do this in remembrance of me
go ahead and partake of your breath
in the same way
after supper he took the cup
he said this cup is the new covenant in
my blood
do this whenever you drink it in
remembrance
of me
go ahead and take
for whenever you eat this bread and you
drink this cup
you proclaim the lord's death
until he comes
in the name of the father
and the son
and the holy spirit
[Music]
we're gonna close with an old song if
you grew up going to church camp
you probably know this song um
so if you all want to stand with us and
sing along it's
the words i think you'll hear echoes of
what brett
was saying tonight just
that it's really about jesus it's not
about me
and
the way that he comes is often through
our weaknesses so let's just sing this
together and remember that
you are my strength and i am weak
[Music]
seeking you as a
oh
[Music]
worthy
is your name
jesus
[Music]
name
taking my sin my cross my shame rising
against your name
[Music]
when i fall down you break me up when i
am dry you fill my cup you are my all in
all
jesus
[Music]
is your name
jesus
[Music]
let's sing it just our voices
jesus
[Music]
name
jesus
[Music]
is your
name
well thank you
thank you so much for being here with us
tonight and um
just for centering on christ remembering
the one who gave his life for us
and
living into that story embracing that
story embracing the pattern it's
beautiful
so thank you for prioritizing that
so if you are new here i want to
encourage you that
we have right there in the hallway a
little table and there's a little card
and you can just fill it out with your
information we'd love to just be in
touch with you um and
yeah just thank you for for coming so
you can fill that out also if you
consider the table home
um we would love for you to um support
this work financially so you can do that
either on that same little box or um
online
so let me send you out uh with this uh
this benediction
you are god's servants
you're gifted with dreams
you're gifted with visions
and upon you rest the grace of god like
flames of living fire
go
love
serve the lord
in the strength of the holy spirit
god bless you all have a great week